this is Joe and this is Noel oh hi hi so
people you know they it sounds like they
know sure yeah
that's remotely plausible yeah it's into
it la people know the writers of TV
shows now like yeah that's true yeah
those are shows that people enjoy thanks
huh
I I have to say the brown blazer is more
TV writer look yeah yeah I mean this is
one of the first things I bought with
your first paycheck like please go get
the brown blaming the guilt now that's
how you get your car to run yeah it
could have the patches you could be a
prick
I mean like I'm roasting you but it's a
smart jacket no Mike Kelly VA health
insurance came at this pocket right it's
very perfectly put you guys are I love
you guys both and the reason I want to
have you both is cuz I love the dual the
dual nature double-helix nature of you
guys Joe a little bit more edgy know a
little bit more sweet yeah edgy sweet
that's true that's true
I guess classic I feel like every time
we go to a party will someone come up
we'll talk and then as the guy walks
away I'm just like that dude yeah I'm
like I like yeah but that's good I think
you you you you yeah and each other's
yang I guess well that's up some people
no one should
that way you you put your penises in
each other's buttons no no we dock them
yeah
do you think that sign language for dock
yeah it is yeah so many people are
googling you can also go this way
what is that but to buy that's about to
but yeah you don't know about but to but
he said it way too quickly to not know
he gently that was reacting whoa